et bien alors Johnny comme maintenant tu es
modèle de boîte de nuit sur va faire une
cabine d'entrevue
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nuit Bon alors c'est base questionnaire
de pous c'est comme dans les
boes
Johnny quel est pour vous le comble de
la
mon vi chez
les faits 20
minutes ou aimerais votre vivre
Encore pour quelle faute as-tu le Plus
d'Inde
[Musique]
bénisse quel est ton personnage
historique
favori que tu as volé
bois quelle est ta qualité préférée chez
l'homme l'humour et chez la
femme la
tendresse qui aurait tu aimé si c'était
pas jny
alid jean
Gabin qui est le personnage principal
défaut mis
Ttu quel est le don de la nature que tu
n'as pas et que tu voudrais avoir s
gabin Je voudrais en avoir une de 30
cm ce que tu dtes par-dessus tout
eux
les pédophiles commentent aimerais
mourir vite quel est l'état présent de
tonne
esprit super bien Je suis ici avec toi
Après tout, c'est bien que tu rejoignes
concevoir vivre c'est vivre Bravo
[Applaudissements]
Miséricorde